are you able to be grateful has it taken
time to take a step back I once read
something there's an article in Sports
Illustrated or something about you a
couple years ago or whatever and how you
went through such a hard time because
you know you had the concussions and you
had the eye injury you went through
hell with the eye thing
I mean hell I know how bad you wanted to
get back I know how you know how hard
you fought to get back but you know you
had limitation yeah there's something
that you know just was this his life
yeah and when how hard was it to finally
accept that did you have to go through
therapy did you have to like will you
say hey I'm like you're hurting
your family inadvertently where you a
pain in the ass to be around were you
miserable the first year when I first
got hurt I remember like three or four
days into being hurt I was sat in my
room in the dark for nine days and you
know I'd try to get up take a leak in
the middle of night I'm falling into
walls I'm all over the place
well why just like my head I couldn't
concussion yeah I just couldn't catch my
bearings how scary is that well at the
time you're not you're probably a little
bit out of it but you're you're also
just trying to get back so yeah I just
always used to push off my niece are
well you don't worry about it you know
oh my head Surround just don't worry
about it you know you just try to push
the stuff aside he's down at the game to
be fine yeah throw a little ice on it
whatever rub some ointment on it he'll
be fine it'll be good you're fine you
know I just always had that old-school
mindset of mind over matter just
don't worry about it it's not it'll
it'll go away or you know it always has
gone away before it'll go away
you know I get my bell rung a few times
I always went away you know and just
this one kind of stuck there and hung
around and hung around and what year was
this ah 2011 yeah it just wouldn't go
away well I just I was getting nauseous
and driving like I had to drive my car
at night with shades on cuz the lights
coming at me bothered a living hell out
of me so I'm driving around my car my
shades you can't even think of playing
and I used to go over the bridge over to
the game rink and you know
I'd used to get so freakin nauseous just
that bum you can remember it now I guess
I could see you feeling awful oh yeah
just starting get sick to your stomach
and then your head gets all up
and I go and then you're showing up with
a range like I'm going on this you
know like ultimately when I when I told
you know when I went to see the doctor
and oh my god you're done he said that
yeah you say like how the are you
playing because I I was playing so I
came back and I played five games and
then I was off why mean I just wasn't
myself and I was nauseous a little
nauseous on the bench you know my eyes
were the bright lights were bothering me
I had a headache you know all of all the
symptoms but again I was just like man
it'll go away and I was actually
getting worse not better
and it was bothering me more and more
funny I'm told the Train I go
something's wrong I see the
doctor so the doctor I see the doctor
and she's like wow we got to send you to
Pittsburgh and go see the concussion guy
and I get there and I see him and he's
looking at my file and you know you fill
out the forms how many concussions have
you had I'm like oh know 100
when you think about it when you're a
kid you're banging your head on the wall
well that's you know when you're seeing
stars you start trying to understand
what is a concussion what is the medical
term and what is the medical diagnosis
of what is a concussion there's so many
different I'm seeing start you know
think about back to when I blacked out I
blacked out I'm seeing stars I got a
stinger I got a you know you know I got
hit one night in LA here friggin stu
bright lights right you would never know
it was an innocuous hit just hit me in
the jaw kind of coming across really
quick it was quick we both fell and then
you were five was I was right beside our
bench I'm like huh
I'm like oh my god as soon as I
open my eyes it two bright lights
coming out and thank God I was right
beside the our bench I just stepped onto
the bench sat down I call the trainer
whoo whoo dude I got two bright lights
you know this is like mid-90s
Danny's I go huh okay well yo can you
play and I'm like yeah I'm good I can
just i sat back in the rocking
and just kind of use my peripheral
vision and look kind of lifted my head
up so the bright lights weren't straight
ahead where everybody was I just kind of
looked at Jesus and you want you here at
all
me I'm out you don't know any
better yes you then that's I play doggy
it's what I do